[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
un mais côté tibhrine hommes ont
gentiment bonjour orione est notre
invité cette semaine et nathalie et
limaces bonjour je rejette député du val
d'oise et vice-présidente du groupe
modem à l'assemblée nationale merci
d'être avec nous merci à vous et dans
l'actualité cette semaine il y a d'abord
le budget son premier volet a été adopté
en commission des finances à l'assemblée
jeudi 6 milliards rendu aux ménages 20
milliards donnés aux entreprises n'y at
il pas là un déséquilibre se sont
interrogés certains députés y compris
dans la majorité le gouvernement lui
explique vouloir garder le cap et fait
de l'investissement sa priorité en
parallèle les débats ont aussi commencé
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale passe d'armes au
sénat sur la réforme de la justice la
loi défendu par la garde des sceaux a
été largement réécrit de cette semaine
les sénateurs se sont notamment opposés
à la ministre sur la question des moyens
et de l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire
le sénat qui en termine avec la sphère
benalla la dernière audition de la
commission denquête s'est tenu cette
semaine c'était la 29e
les sénateurs devraient rendre leurs
conclusions dans les prochaines semaines
et puis une loi qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité loin de là
la loi sur la lutte contre la
manipulation de l'information les
fameuses fox news a été adoptée mardi à
l'assemblée le texte va maintenant
retourner au sénat qu'il avait rejeté en
juillet le jugeant inutile et dangereux
et on entame cette semaine avec le
budget examiné par les députés en
commission des finances
[Musique]
le gouvernement le présente comme le
budget du pouvoir d'achat mettant en
avant 6 milliards d'euros de baisses
d'impôts pour les ménages une première
depuis dix ans mais lors de l'examen du
texte en commission des députés y
compris de la majorité ont demandé un
rééquilibrage du texte le jugeant trop
favorable aux entreprises
stéphanie de pierre le budget 2010 9
est il trop favorable aux entreprises
c'est l'angle d'attaqué de la gauche
mais même du côté de la majorité des
voix s'élèvent pour dire qu'il faut
rééquilibrer le projet du gouvernement
la députée emilie carew soutenu par les
communistes s'opposent à un renforcement
de la niche copé pour les entreprises en
gros les entreprises paieront peut-être
un peu plus diesse et en retour on va
élargir la niche copé et leur permettre
de récupérer un peu plus d'argent
il n'y a aucune étude d'impact qui est
fait là dessus d'une part et d'autre
part quand on voit ce que coûte la niche
copé au budget de l'état
quand même ça fait tousser en 2017 c'est
4 milliards 4 et en 2010 8,7 milliards
des études d'impact sur une année ça ne
suffit pas il faut utiliser plusieurs
années et puis même sur le fondement
même de cette compensation moi je pense
que c'est excessif
la hausse du diesel divise l'opposition
et la majorité majorité qui cherchent le
bon équilibre entre fiscalité écologique
et pouvoir d'achat
le député matthieu orphelin pointe le
problème du prix du pétrole
on a certes augmenté cette fiscalité
écologique sur les carburants
c'est entre 4 et 7 centimes on l'assumé
il faut le faire c'est très bien mais
c'est pas ça que les gens ont vu à la
pompe à la pompe ils ont vu 30 centimes
en plus parce que 22 centimes et on
pourrait tous les chiffres sont là 22
centimes de la hausse depuis un an sont
dus non pas la trajectoire de fiscalité
écologique qu'il faut bien sûr maintenir
mais à la hausse du prix du baril quand
on prend un ménage de parents deux
enfants
qui se chauffent au fioul domestique et
qui roulent au diesel ce qui est quand
même très fréquemment le cas dans les
territoires ruraux
la hausse des taxes hors tva en moyenne
pour une seule voiture et en général ils
ont deux voitures pour une seule voiture
ça a été l'an dernier 250 euros sur
l'écologie la majorité s'inquiète pour
les agriculteurs bio en l'absence
d'acompte le prélèvement à la source
risque de fragiliser leur trésorerie un
amendement propose d'y remédier grâce au
soutien des députés la république en
marche s'il est adopté contre l'avis du
rapporteur du budget l'amendement est
adopté les amendements sont adoptés
toujours sur le prélèvement à la source
la droite parvient à faire passer un
amendement pour plus de transparence
le fisc devra donner ses calculs au
contribuable l'atelier limaces le
gouvernement présente ce budget comme
celui du pouvoir d'achat mais ce que ce
sont vraiment les français les grands
gagnants de ce budget oui il me semble
que ce sont les français en effet les
grands gagnants de ce budget d'abord moi
je veux saluer je veux saluer la
présentation de ce budget comme étant je
pense sincère volontaire et respectueux
des engagements qui ont été pris par par
emmanuel macron c'est d'abord une
promesse tenue celle de l'amélioration
des services publics
on le retrouve avec notamment une
augmentation de 4,4 pour cent sur la
justice le régalien est renforcée
notamment par les armées ou l'éducation
nationale donc un budget sincère et qui
tient ses promesses
et puis aussi il est l'expression de la
stratégie des réformes à moyen et long
terme
engagé par par le président de la
république et puis évidemment bien sûr
il ya comme une baisse significative des
impôts cette année 6 milliards d'euros
ça n'est pas rien il ya une volonté
réelle et sérieuse d'aller vers plus de
pouvoir d'achat et notamment ce mois
d'octobre on aura un impact là imminent
immédiat puisque les français perçoivent
déjà sur leur feuille d'imposition une
réduction de la taxe d'habitation qui
d'environ 200 euros à peu près par
parfois lent pour vous n'a pas besoin de
rééquilibrage dans ce texte c'était pas
trop favorable aux entreprises
rééquilibrage en tout cas moi je pense
surtout que c'est une mesure c'est un
texte sur lequel je crois on s'est
engagé un petit peu comme des
équilibristes en effet parce
on a effectivement cette réduction des
impôts on à la réduction de la dépense
publique quand même il faut qu'on en
parle on est à 80 milliards d'euros
c'est 4 points du pib ça n'est pas
anodin et puis on a aussi quelque chose
qui va falloir aborder de façon
décomplexée et sérieuses et la réduction
de la dépense alors on en a parlé dans
ce sujet par exemple prenons un exemple
ce qu'on appelle la niche copé il s'agit
d'une exonération d'impôt sur les
plus-values à long terme sur les
cessions de filiales des titres de
participation le gouvernement
souhaitaient abaisser la part de la de
ces plus values taxé de 12 à 5 % coût
estimé à peu près 3 milliards finalement
il a fait machine arrière
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas dans ce budget le
risque de retomber dans l'image du
budget pour les riches qui est
l'étiquette qui avaient collé au budget
non je ne crois pas puisque encore une
fois je vous reparler de ces 6 milliards
d'impôts de la taxe d'habitation et de
toutes les mesures qui sont prises quand
même pour aller soutenir les plus
défavorisés et notamment la prime
d'activité l'allocation d'adulte
handicapé enfin il ya un certain nombre
de mesures qui vont dans ce sens non là
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que vous dites
alors on va avancer sur un autre texte
budgétaire ce qui l'a été aussi discuté
cette semaine à l'assemblée c'est le
projet de loi de financement la sécurité
sociale cette fois ci il prévoit
notamment de nouvelles économies sur les
médicaments écouté la ministre de la
santé mme yasmina je veux mentionner
également nous souhait de poursuivre le
développement des génériques la
responsabilité de l'assurance maladie
c'est de rembourser à efficacité
thérapeutique égale le médicament le
moins onéreux
s'il n'y a pas de motif médical à la
délivrance du princeps
alors qu'il existe un générique moins
chère c'est à dire que s'il n'ya pas
mention sur l' ordonnance de non
substituables il n'y a aucune raison de
faire supporter un surcoût à l'assurance
maladie
je propose dans ce cas que le princeps
ce soit à l'avenir remboursés sur la
base du générique en atelier limaces
d'abord une question de méthode le texte
avait été présenté en conseil des
ministres mercredi matin
vous avez commencé son examen mercredi
soir en commission on vient le
on parle de 58 d'articles 170 pages de
loi est ce qu'en tant que député on peut
travailler dans cet urgence absolument
pas et d'ailleurs je vous remercie de me
poser cette question parce que dans tous
les cas je vous en aurait parlé en effet
nous avons auditionné
madame la ministre des solidarités de la
santé est également monsieur darmanin
mercredi soir nous avons reçu le texte
très précisément à 17h46 58 article 177
pages et surtout et c'est peut-être le
document le plus important puisque nous
avions quand même un pré-projet la
semaine dernière l'étude d'impact
l'étude d'impact qui nous permet
d'apporter des précisions des
modifications des amendements de façon
sérieuse au texte un document de 500
pages donc non véritablement on ne peut
pas travailler dans ces conditions on ne
peut pas amendée s'imprégner
correctement du texte dans ces
conditions alors madame bourguignon la
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales d'ailleurs là la très
très bien dit le parlement n'est pas une
variable d'ajustement et le travail les
travaux des parlementaires doivent
vraiment être respectée sur ce qu'on a
entendu sur les médicaments vous
soutenez cette mesure sur les génériques
oui moi je pense que c'est une bonne
mesure dès lors que comme l'a dit la
ministre sur le principe est on est on
est à la situation équivalente
il n'y a pas de raison d'aller vers un
médicament qui va être plus cher sauf si
véritablement c'est préciser sur
l'ordonnancé un non substituables par le
médecin dans des conditions très
précises mais sinon puisque l'on va vers
les économies et d'ailleurs il faut
quand même souligner le budget cette
année des comptes de la sécurité sociale
quand même un budget qui est
excédentaire pour la première fois
depuis 18 ans il reste en effet une
dette abyssale importante à résorber
d'ici 2024
mais tout ça justement va dans le bon
sens si on veut résorber la dette
il faut faire des choix il faut prendre
des décisions claires et celle ci en est
une
les pensions de retraite seront
quasiment gelé 1 elles augmenteront de 0
3% alors que l'inflation de sa
supérieure à 2% est ce que ce
gouvernement fait peser trop d'effort
sur les retraités alors c'est le sujet
et c'est vrai qu'on est un petit peu en
train de stigmatiser les retraités
contre les actifs alors pour ce qui est
de la retraite
en dehors d'un article spécifique sur la
csg
ce sujet ne sera pas abordée à
l'occasion du plfss mais bien dans un
texte totalement totalement distinct sur
la csg
le groupe modem et apparentés avait
présenté l'année dernière des
amendements visant à relever le seuil de
déclenchement effectivement de la csg
puisque nous estimions que ce qui était
proposé était et est largement
insuffisant et d'ailleurs je me réjouis
et je me félicite que alors que ces
amendements n'ont pas été adoptés
l'année dernière le gouvernement il soit
revenu et finalement c'est 300 milles à
350 mille retraités qui vont en
bénéficier de cette mesure dans l'année
à venir alors il ya un autre sujet c'est
l'alcool des médecins est écrit cette
semaine à la ministre de la santé il
estime que la lutte contre l'alcoolisme
est absent de ce budget il demande de
taxer plus fortement l'alcool pour
financer un fonds de prévention qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
alors la prévention elle est pourtant
bien présente dans ce dans ce texte elle
était l'année dernière elle est vraiment
en première ligne dans le plan ma santé
c'est vrai qu' il n'y a pas suffisamment
de focus cette année en tout cas sur
l'alcool mais on continue à le faire
notamment sur les différentes
dépendances et en particulier sur le
tabac de tabac on l'a introduit l'année
dernière l'idée c'est de l'amener à 10
euros le paquet de cigarettes
c'est à la fois dans le sens de la
prévention des jeunes et puisqu'on est
en octobre quand même je me permets une
petite parenthèse c'est trop c'est aussi
très important dans la lutte contre
contre le cancer
mais je reste néanmoins d'accord avec
vous il faut il faudra en tout cas à
l'avenir mettre l'accent sur sur cette
question allez on en vient à notre
deuxième thème la réforme de la justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte porté par la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet a été débattu cette
semaine au sénat il prévoit une hausse
de 24% des moyens de la justice
en quatre ans il accorde aussi plus de
moyens au parquet les sénateurs ont très
largement modifié la version initiale du
texte
le résumé est signée sandra cerqueira
sur la réforme de la justice
le sénat est en désaccord et dénoncent
un texte inabouti il reproche au
gouvernement l'insuffisance de la hausse
des crédits
les sénateurs de droite ont même fait
voter une promesse d' emmanuel macron la
création de 15000 places de prison d'ici
un amendement qui a donné lieu à des
échanges animés en séance avec la
ministre nicole belloubet je sais que
vous êtes soucieuse et rigoureuse dans
vos propos je crois que c'est important
de simplement de 10,6 de de valider une
fois pour toutes le fait que le
programme présidentiel a été revu par
deux et vous savez très bien parce que
vous êtes un élu du territoire que ce
n'est pas simple de trouver des terrains
vous le savez très bien qu'il ya des
procédures à respecter vous savez très
bien qu'il ya des analyses de terrain à
faire vous le savez très bien qu'il ya
des dossiers à construire il faut pour
cela du temps un peu de calme nouvelle
passe d'armes concernant le renforcement
des pouvoirs du parquet voulue par le
gouvernement avec la mise sur écoute ou
l'anc est sous pseudonyme pour les
crimes et délits passibles de trois ans
de prison pour le sénat cette réforme
porte atteinte aux libertés
individuelles non rapporteurs ont eux
très longuement discuté avec les
représentants des juges des libertés et
de la détention
ils en ont retiré la conviction absolue
qu'il ne serait pas en mesure d'exercer
un contrôle utiles sur l'exercice par
les procureurs des pouvoirs que vous
voulez leur donner incompréhension de la
garde des sceaux qui craint un retour en
arrière notamment dans les enquêtes en
matière de pornographie infantile
il faut quand même avoir ici
la préoccupation des victimes il me
semble que il y a beaucoup d'affaires
beaucoup d'affaires qui ont été résolus
grâce à ces techniques utilisées pour
des crimes de droit commun souvent très
grave
malgré les promesses des couteaux chacun
reste campé sur ses positions
les débats sont rapides avec une
ministre de la justice systématiquement
mise en minorité
le vote solennel du texte aura lieu le
23 octobre prochain
oui monsieur le alors les sénateurs
dénoncent un texte inaboutie notamment
sur la question des moyens accordés à la
justice est ce que vous êtes d'accord
non là je suis pas d'accord il ya quand
même 1,6 milliard d'euros qui sont
investis un projet de création de 6500
postes ans c'est l'équivalent sur le
budget de 4,4 pour cent d'augmentation
c'est l'un des budgets et qui progresse
et qui va s'élever le plus vite et aussi
fortement donc non je crois que les
moyens ils sont mis justement pour
aboutir à cette réforme à une bonne
réforme qui d'ailleurs va être conduite
est menée par nicole belloubet qui est
une garde des sceaux qui est extrêmement
de mon point de vue compétente sur le
sujet qui travaillent en collaboration
véritablement avec les parlementaires
pour aller dans le bon sens
donc moi je suis plutôt rassuré dans le
texte du gouvernement il ya 7000 places
de prisons construites d'ici 2022 le
sénat a lui voté la construction de 15
mai place c'était la promesse d'
emmanuel macron est-ce que c'était une
promesse irréaliste ça n'est pas une
promesse irréaliste on l'a vu dans votre
reportage il ya quand même un sujet
majeur c'est le sujet du foncier qu'il
faut trouver véritablement 7000 places
c'est déjà une étape mais elle est
importante quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
la surpopulation carcérale est d'environ
150 %
c'est énorme donc il faut véritablement
travailler à l'efficacité au sens de la
peine pour améliorer cette situation qui
d'ailleurs est contrebalancé par des
chiffres qui sont aussi inquiétants dans
l'autre sens c'est seulement 75% le taux
d'encadrement
donc on a énormément de détenus et on a
insuffisamment
de d'encadrants donc là c'est tout le
sens de la réforme justement qu'il un
qui va nous être proposées alors on l'a
entendu ce texte prévoit notamment
d'élargir le pouvoir des procureurs qui
pourront demander des écoutes
téléphoniques des géolocalisation pour
tous les délits passibles d'une peine de
3 ans d'emprisonnement ou plus est-ce
que ce projet de ne pas trop de pouvoir
au parquet non je ne pense pas après sur
ces questions là j'ai fait quelques
auditions et moi si je commence à
travailler sur le texte je crois que
techniquement de toute façon ça ne
fonctionne pas bien donc là je pense
qu'il faudra il faudra y revenir
plus globalement sur la réforme de la
justice l'idée quand même c'est de
simplifier et c'est d'alléger
effectivement les procédures notamment
sur le civil d'aller davantage sur
l'amiable puisque l'on sait que les
tribunaux sont engorgés et il faut
recentrer le juge et les juges
véritablement sur leurs missions et sur
leurs fonctions cette semaine au sénat
bien le sénat a terminé les auditions
dans la sphère benalla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est sophie at l'ancien chef de la
sécurité sous françois hollande qui aura
donc été la dernière auditionné au total
ce sont 29 audition à laquelle auquel
ont procédé la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale dont celle d'alexandre
benalla lui même la commission denquête
va maintenant rédiger un rapport attendu
dans les prochaines semaines quand un
calme et oublier les dizaines de caméras
et de photographes comme lors de la
venue d'alexandre benalla au sénat pour
cette toute dernière audition le calme
est de retour c'est sophie at ancienne
patronne de la sécurité sous françois
hollande qui était convoqué et ce afin
d'apporter son expertise en matière de
sécurité du président de la république
j'étais en charge de la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
le chef puis la chef de cabine est est
en charge de l'organisation des
déplacements
notre travail de collaboration a été
extrêmement clair je ne me suis jamais
chargé d'organiser les déplacements du
président un public
il ou elle ne s'est jamais chargé
d'organiser la sécurité rapprochée du
président un public
elle n'aurait pas où il n'aurait pas
accepté que je je je je je sois sur son
domaine de compétence et je n'aurais
jamais accepté que quelqu'un prenne
place sur le mien les attributions de
chacun pendant le précédent quinquennat
était donc très clair al'inverse de la
situation décrite depuis le début de la
sphère benalla il peut apparaître que
monsieur benalla était un organisateur
de voyages
il peut apparaître qu'il était un garde
du corps ou quelqu'un qui assure et de
fait une sécurité rapprochée notamment
dans les voyages déplacements privés il
peut apparaître qu'il n'avait aucune
mission de sécurité
aucune ça nous a été dit sous serment
vous dis cela parce que tout ce que j'ai
dit ici est attestée par des
déclarations publiques faites sous
serment tout charge désormais aux
sénateurs de recouper toutes ces
déclarations pour leur rapport attendu
dans les prochaines semaines et nous
avons maintenant
à établir ce qui sera notre conviction
profonde sur les dysfonctionnements
éventuels qui ont pu être identifiés sur
la sécurité du président de la
république rôle d'alexandre benalla à
l'elysée permis de port d'armes réalité
de la sanction sur tous ces points les
zones d'ombré demeurent
charge désormais aux sénateurs de se
faire une intime conviction en la
matière
les auditions dans cette affaire benalla
sont donc terminés on attend un rapport
de la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
quel bilan vous faites de cette
commission à ce qu'elle aurait été utile
alors moi je ne vais pas entrer dans le
dans le débat et dans ce sujet là
justement parce que d'abord c'est du
passé je n'ai pas siéger dans ces
commissions et enfin je crois surtout
que ça n'intéresse pas les français
voilà ce qui intéresse les français
aujourd'hui c'est leur pouvoir d'achat
ce qui intéresse les français
aujourd'hui c'est la sauvegarde et elles
ont été regardées mais voilà c'était
peut-être le feuilleton de l'été mais
aujourd'hui on est passé à autre chose
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est la
sécurité dans les communes on l'a pas
dit tout à l'heure mais dans le plfss à
venir ses 30000 places en crèches
supplémentaires
c'est une santé qui fonctionne voilà
donc des sujets qui les impacts des
directement du rapport ne pourront pas
être utile à l'avenir elles pourront
l'être en tout cas deuxième chose la
justice fait son travail il convient de
la laisser travailler sereinement et on
verra ce qu'il en ressortira oncle était
temps que cette affaire se termine il
était temps que cette affaire se termine
en effet mais nous nous sommes au
travail aujourd'hui sur des sujets qui
sont de mon point de vue bien plus
importants 1 comme les finances de
l'état et la santé des français
allez on en vient notre dernier thème la
loi contre la manipulation de
l'information
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la langue française s'est enrichi d'un
nouveau mot cette semaine un fox c'est
le terme désormais préconisé pour parler
d'échec news ces fausses informations
apparues notamment au moment de la
campagne présidentielle c'est contre ces
dérives que la loi a voté mardi à
l'assemblée entend lutter mais les
moyens qu'elle prévoit divise
profondément explications allait
souffrir deux propositions de lois ont
été votées pour lutter contre la
manipulation de l'information en période
électorale ce qui a animé les débats
c'est ce nouveau mécanisme de référé
jusqu'à trois mois avant le scrutin
national un candidat ou un parti peut
saisir le juge des référés pour faire
cesser la diffusion de ces fausses
informations mécanisme défendu sur le
banc du gouvernement par françoise
nyssen en pleine préparation du
remaniement
ce dont nous avons besoin en période
électorale c'est d'une réponse rapide
permettant d'endiguer la diffusion d'une
information manifestement fausses
lorsqu'elle s'inscrit dans une campagne
de manipulation délibérée et orchestré
ce référé ne porte en rien atteinte à la
liberté d'expression ou au droit à
l'information
la procédure est jugée inutile par
l'opposition alexis corbière s'agace
même en évoquant la dernière
présidentielle
le phénomène majeur en matière de presse
lors l'élection présidentielle c'est pas
ce que ce pique nique de manière
confidentielle hadid emmanuel macron
c'est ce que 100% et mais n'y en aurait
pas tes d'emmanuel macron qu'il était le
seul candidat en capacité batman à mme
le pen qui était le seul candidat à
pouvoir apporter de réponse en ce pays
oui c'est le fait que des éditorialistes
ont expliqué que nous voulions une
alliance militaire avec l'iran avec des
antisémites
ça a été dit au micro d'une grande
chaîne de radio ou m'insulter et à
l'insulter mes amis et vous l'avez tous
répété tous les garde-fous sont
instaurés répond la ministre
un conseil de déontologie de la presse
devrait voir le jour et les pouvoirs du
csa seront renforcées le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel pourra
suspendre la diffusion d'un service
contrôler ou sous influence d'un état
étranger
le texte repart au sénat pour sa
dernière navette avant le scrutin final
alors nathalie masse beaucoup de doutes
ont été exprimés sur cette loi
inefficace pour les uns inutile pour les
autres est-ce que vous l'a défendu alors
notre groupe a voté le texte considérant
quand même qu'il y a une utilité dans ce
texte justement pour lutter contre la
manipulation
à titre personnel je considère que c'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga on est bien
d'accord
c'est un pied dans la porte je crois que
ce texte il convient de le laisser vivre
et de voir comment on peut l'améliorer
l'amendé deux choses d'abord
effectivement il ya la liberté de la
presse et il convient de la laisser
s'exprimer avec une information
évidemment fiables et vérifiées d'une
part et d'autre part là je crois qu'on
est plus quand même le ciblage c'est
quand même davantage les réseaux sociaux
où on voit un certain nombre de dérives
régulièrement donc on a voté le texte
voyons ce que ça donne et puis je crois
qu'il a il a matière à vivre et à être
amendé a évolué
est ce que ce texte sera même applicable
c'est la question que se posent certains
c'est oui c'est une c'est une question
qui est assez juste en effet maintenant
vos ya quand même des leviers
aujourd'hui avec notamment la procédure
de référé ou l'élargissement des
pouvoirs du csa encore une fois il faut
le il faut le laisser vivre et puis et
puis on verra ce qui est ce qu'il
advient on va terminer cette semaine
avec le groupe socialiste au sénat qui a
déposé une demande de commission
d'enquêté sur les abus sexuels commis au
sein de l'église en france
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
patrick kanner nous pensons que une
intervention extérieure permettra de
faire avancer les choses et notamment de
mettre toute la lumière sur ce qui est
peut-être un système d'étouffement de
dissimulation
organisée l'église en tout cas n'a pas
su trouver la solution qui aujourd'hui
font qu'il y à des milliers de jeunes
qui ont été victimes d'actes pédophiles
pendant des années attali les masses
souhaitez vous que cette commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale voit le jour j'ai
toujours un petit peu partagés sur la
démultiplication des créations de
commission denquête comme ça pour autant
c'est un sujet qui me tient quand même
particulièrement à coeur puisque vous
savez l'année dernière j'ai beaucoup
travaillé dans le cadre du du texte
porté par marlène schiappa sur les
violences sexuelles donc exercer sur sur
mineurs donc je ne sais pas si c'est le
bon véhicule
en tout cas je crois important et
pertinent de l'amener au coeur du débat
politique oui il faut la question se
pose au sénat de savoir s'il faut aussi
reconstruire cette commission denquête
l'église catholique ou l'élargir quel
est votre avis sur cette question et
basse et c'est tout le sujet
véritablement parce que bon toutou ces
actes de pédophilie n'da bord ne touche
pas que l'église
on l'a vu récemment dans des affaires
qui concernaient des personnels qui
encadrent les enfants dans l'est dans
les écoles ou dans les dans les centres
donc voilà il ya un vrai sujet et puis
au delà de ça il ya aussi la l'inceste
voilà donc le sujet est vaste je crois
qu'il mérite d'être posée est ce que
c'est le bon véhicule ou pas encore une
fois je ne sais pas mais c'est un sujet
qu'il faut poser et je m'y investir est
évidemment merci beaucoup merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous cette semaine et
nous thibault on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]